a couple days before our period comes
don't mess with me
would your ex boyfriend say the same
they would they would they would attest
hang on let me just try and clarify this
are you saying that as a woman you are
acknowledging
that
when you're coming your period you are
differently emotionally the days before
yeah
oh my gosh hormonally yeah you literally
are
yeah i'll cry and i'm like why am i
crying all right all right so
if a man was to say
right so you've already acknowledged it
right so if so if a man wants to say
you know what you're coming your period
you're probably a little bit emotional
how would you respond to that well first
of all
when you say that obviously that would
piss the woman off yeah but hang on hang
on but hang on it doesn't make any sense
because you've already acknowledged it
well yes you already know you've
acknowledged the fact that you are
different when you're coming in your
period
but hang on when a man acknowledges it
and says to you uh you know what you're
coming through with you a little bit why
is it why is it going to piss you off
because he's telling the truth i think
because you're asking this question you
already kind of know the answer
i mean
come on
i'm just saying why get pissed off with
me
my friend used to do that to me
wait i agree with what he's saying so i
feel like it's all sort of how a man
says it like in what context that
conversation is in but it's true like if
he's saying that he acknowledges it say
you were also ignored as a woman like i
go through these like pre-menstrual uh
mood swings or post-mental or even
during when men's your menstrual cycle
like why is it crazy if the man says it
to you as a as ammo not even ammo not
ammo it's just a
relationship an acknowledgement yeah an
acknowledgement
i can i can see you
like as i think because
it kind of diminished it feels it's a
pathogenizing it makes them feel like
you're diminishing what they feel when
you say so it's a feelings thing yes
right so that's what and that's the
thing you like men don't men process
information differently from women right
and so a man will be very logical with
his with his uh conclusion he'll be like
oh you know what this woman is acting
this way because okay maybe she's coming
the period right okay cool this woman's
acting this way because she's common
appeared and i'm just gonna say it
listen babe you're acting you're not
acting right because you're coming
period but hang on
you you as a woman
yeah are saying
that's gonna piss me off
but it's in the truth
we can't handle the chances
if you're talking logical and this has
happened to you how many times
wait wait wait wait multiple times
multiple times now right and so if it's
happened to you once then why wouldn't
it get through your thick [ __ ] skull
that would happen the next time no
because what i'm trying to do is i'm
trying to make you understand that
you're being irrational right now
irrational yeah you're being irrational
because i'm telling you the truth
and you can't handle it right if i tell
you the sky is blue and you go crazy
because the sky's blue now i'm gonna be
like what the hell is wrong with you
like just calm the [ __ ] down right what
it doesn't make sense it's like i'm
telling you this guy's blue it's it's a
tree it's a fact like why are you so
crazy about a fact
i don't get it i don't get it so you're
saying that
um
because i have brothers group around
boys so i i understand right not fully
how they process because
but
so if someone comes to you saying
something correct and you get hurt like
if i say hey like you have a hair
sticking up like you need to like do
something with that and you were like
well why should come to me saying that
is that something that the man needs to
check or you need to check how you
accept how they're saying
and i'm not saying i'm not saying just
you i'm just saying just i'm here for
this conversation in general is that
something whenever someone comes to you
and they're
there
and they're just
no and
people say something to you and they
don't mean it that way but you take it
that way is that something you need to
analyze yourself okay why why did i take
that that way or yeah do i talk to them
and be like hey
did you say it this way
accountability is a thing
right maybe it's the tone
no but the thing is but and that's the
thing that sometimes men
like a man will generally men will
generally speak straightforward does
that mean we're not i would say so yeah
we're not talking about that we're not
going about it
we're not worrying about what type of
time of the month it is for you
we'll just say hey listen this is a cup
but i would say what you mean it's a cup
but it's like yo yo
different like you know like even as a
female i could go up to another female
like say i'm not really defensive i'm
like you know what your hair's sticking
up here well i think ego is such a big
thing for a female yeah oh yeah i think
people always put ego on men no honey
it's females as well and i feel like
they're like what do you mean like
they're just straight on smoke and it's
just not i
i've said women don't like women
generally yeah i agree like exactly
women and it depends on the country like
other women because
because women are women's competition
and so
if you if i said if you were to bring
another three women in here yeah right
the women would be like analyzing these
women like [ __ ] these babies
right you know what i'm saying [ __ ]
right so women generally don't like
women did that happen when i came late
who the [ __ ] is
when men men's competition for another
man is different from a woman's country
because a man will a man will look at a
man's
success
when we look at men as a man we look at
another defined success all right so you
look at jay-z or puff daddy or warren
buffett or let's bring it down to your
level a man a man will look at another
man's success and maybe be envious of
his success yeah we don't generally i'm
not saying it doesn't happen we don't
generally look at other men and be like
look he's looking look at what he's
wearing i don't think you're what's he
why why is he wearing that
i'm
i'm not saying men don't do it but men
don't look at other men and think oh my
god look at his hair what what okay look
at his boots
women do that women look at other
women's shoes and get jealous of that
[ __ ] and start doing it
[Applause]
[Music]
there are some that don't but
i've i've experienced some men that do
and but it's not the
vast majority but i do agree with you
that
i feel like women
not all women but some women are more
materialistic so what we see is what
we're going to analyze we're not going
to think about anything else because we
don't see that we don't know what's
going on we don't care about that but
men are like okay like
i don't they just don't think about
looks it just like doesn't cross their
mind to be like that man looks better
than me another nice looks and they just
they just
act the way they act i would say that a
man and correct me for wrong they would
be
more intimidated or not even intimidated
but analyze a person's personality and
how they carry themselves
more than women would all right so this
is the thing if a man
if a man walks in a room right
and
women flock towards that man like they
go
like the other men are thinking oh who
the [ __ ] is he like
what's going on with him like does he is
he someone that i don't know
and
we might look at that and wonder to
ourselves why is he getting the female
attention that we're not getting
but we don't look at
generally
his looks
we're one we're wondering
what is it about this man
that has all the women
going towards him and normally
it's success yeah
you know what i mean like normally it's
success
i find that men more like
how they dress i feel like funny
yeah like the character is so
characteristic so how you portray
yourself do you know what it's image let
me let me actually get down to it it's
actually image like how you portray
yourself like because when you say when
it comes to social status
social status i don't know you yet so
it's like i could be attracted to you
and it's like i don't believe i don't
know you okay i'm sorry
that's not the conversation
okay i'm talking i'm just asking a
question
i'm just asking the question
see you walk into the room i could be so
attracted to you but it's like that's
not based on the person i don't know who
the hell you are
like but that's just me looking at you
how you dress
me personally how you dress how you look
how you like maybe carried yourself into
the room that like you're over your
energy but it's not me like saying oh
that's your personality that's me just
looking at you but that's like but even
men they look at that and they're like
oh like that's how we dress they look
like materialistic stuff as well not
like women though
like look this is the thing like you you
you no but you're you you you you're
arguing something that's just like you
keep arguing for the exception you do
this all the time it's not the rule like
like
80 80 of like consumer debt is women
eighty percent of consumer buying
decisions is by women right women buy
most [ __ ] right everything is marketed
towards women yeah yeah so that's like
this these are like
whatever it is
why argue except